the Joe Rogan experience have I told you
my xylitol story I wanted to tell you
this
silence you chew gum I know you do I
remember like after show like you chew
gum right sure
do you use xylitol gum tell you my story
that all is it's like it's from the
birch plant we were just talking about
it's the natural it's naturally found in
plants so it's that birch you know what
they're whipping it's from that plant it
yes it is used as a like if you're
eating it you know I think it could
cause like like the river that all kind
of thing effect where it's like too much
GI distress but when you're chewing gum
or using toothpaste these many studies
have shown that it kills anaerobic
bacteria like streptococcus Octus
mutants that cause cavities
and dental decay really so so here's my
story like multiple studies in humans
showing this it's like a big deal so I
went this is before I was before I had
my son I went to the dentist my dentist
really he's great and he did an x-ray
we're doing a cleaning you know that's a
hygiene thing and and he comes back and
he's like you've got two cavities
cavities I don't know any sugar like you
know I've just I've got like a bad oral
microbiome or something that I've just
for four years or I don't know I
shouldn't have cavities because I don't
need sugar but anyways I had some
because you have two cavities they're at
the point of no return where you know
like you there
I guess they penetrate the enamel a
certain amount and they're like you have
to you have to like get them out and so
the way I am is I always like to like
look into everything before I do
anything it's like okay this is not my
field I understand I told them I'm like
I'm gonna do some reading research and
see if I can find you know if there's
any you know possibility that don't have
to like get a filling right and he's
like okay well if you find anything
please send it my way so so then I found
out it was pregnant and I was so I was
like okay well I can't go back to
dentist and at that point I I was like
looking through everything all my
toiletries and everything like what do I
have to get rid of what's in there that
could be harmful and so I was like
fluoride like in my toothpaste so I was
like I don't want to use fluoride
toothpaste anymore and these stories are
going to connect but so
fluoride fluoride has been shown a lot
of people are worried about the effects
on the brain and the only solid evidence
I could find on negative effects of
fluoride on the brain are in utero
meaning pregnant women and you know and
the effects on babies and I don't know
if toothpaste has enough to even do
anything but in my mind I was like no
getting rid of the fluoride you know I
got a I got a water filter that got rid
of the fluoride in the water and I was
like doing all that so I came across
this xylitol toothpaste - hi Lata
toothpaste so I started doing research
on xylitol while I was looking for
alternatives so I was like tom's of
Maine I can't use that crap I've tried
it before it's like makes your ass smell
worse anyway so so I was like I've got
to find something other than Thompson
Maine so I came across societal stuff
and I started doing research and then I
found all these studies I'm not only did
I find studies that like it you know
basically kills these bacteria that
cause cavities that s mutants pregnant
women that choose I'll eat all gum by
the way the studies were with gum not
the truth base that people were chewing
this gum and pregnant pregnant women
like they were like six months pregnant
starting start at six months and they
chewed this xylitol gum all the way up
until anywhere between the child you
know the baby being six months and there
were some studies that went out like a
year and then they met the the the
researchers measured the oral bacteria
of the toddlers and then they measured
in multiple years out as they became
children and the mothers chewing it
chewing the gum it lowered the incidence
of the nest Newton's in the children
because you know mothers kiss their kids
and you transfer and oral bacteria and
so they're like they're chewing the
xylitol gum had a positive effect on the
child's oral microbiome and I was like
yeah I'm gonna do this I was like I gave
myself
TMJ like I chewed so much xylitol gum
while I was pregnant and like I still
like to this day I chew I have some with
me right now but TMJ is the right thing
like it was like copying my job was I
was eating a lot of sauteed kale and
chewing a lot of xylitol gum when I was
pregnant
and so but it totally fixed itself
thankfully so anyways a year goes by I
have I have my son I've been should I'm
like okay I gotta go back to Dennis
because you know pregnancy makes your
teeth worse there's like all this stuff
about you bleeding your gums bleed
there's like there's some kind of term
where like women get like like what's
that periodontitis or gingivitis one of
those two it's bad anyways so I go back
to Dennis we do the x-rays and I'm like
oh you're gonna tell me about the stupid
cavities and I haven't done the research
you know and it goes he comes in and he
goes I've never seen this before but
your cavities are gone he shows the
x-rays and he shows me before and after
he's like they're totally gone and and I
was like that's amazing as like is it
the pregnancy's did he's like no he's
like we get women coming in you're after
pain is like worse and I said the only
thing that I did like I could think of
is like my obsessive xylitol gum chewing
which I still do and the fact that it
does decrease that you know I don't know
how it would affect an already formed
cavity but my cavities are gone
Wow so my doctor my I see that my
dentist is great because he like you
know any dentist could just be like nope
they're still there like I don't know
what the x-ray supposed to look like you
know so so I feel like he's a
trustworthy guy I worry about shifty
Dennis right yeah but you do right right
so that is crazy so the xylitol gums
somehow knee so you think that what it
did was affect your the microbiome
morale oh and it's showed there's also
studies showing that it decreases the
incidence of I said I'm talking about
Staphylococcus mutants because it's the
only one I remember but there's another
one that causes dental decay but it
didn't affect any of the good bacteria
in the mouth
well so um so I was like now I'm just
like it's all staff a caucus mutant that
that's the same is that the same family
that you get from staph infections no no
different stuff yeah okay but I mean
there's lots of different Staphylococcus
blah blah blah blah you know okay so
it's so the xylitol gum Joe you need to
get on it it's really awesome
[Applause]